Olá,
minhas amigas, meus amigos. Muito boa
noite. É um prazer estar aqui com vocês.
Deixa eu só pegar meu óculos.
Boa noite, Cleidivan, Rosângela, Vilma,
PAS, Eliseu,
Vilma, Cristina Carol,
como é que foi o passagem de ano para
vocês? Foi tudo bem?
Espero que tenha corrido tudo
maravilhosamente bem.
E como sempre eu peço para vocês que me
deem o feedback. O áudio está bom? O paz
de 2008, o pessoal gosta de colocar uns
nomes esquisito, né, na
às vezes até difícil de falar.
Nossa, até com janela antirruído dá para
escutar a moto. Impressionante.
Vocês estão me escutando bem? Boa noite,
Luciano. Tô esperando o feedback de
vocês para dar seguimento.
Pronto.
OK. A Vilma tá dando um sim, quer dizer
que tá escutando bem. Então, bom, vamos
começar aqui, pessoal. Se tiver algum
problema de áudio, depois vocês me
falam, tá? Ah, eu queria saber de vocês
também, quem é que tá acompanhando do
celular e quem tá acompanhando do
computador e quem tá usando o link
paisagem, quem tá usando o link retrato.
Eu tô curioso para saber se o layout do
retrato, né, o link de celular, se ele
tá legal.
Corretor Ângelo, boa noite. Me fale se
esse layout aqui que tem no Streamyard
de retrato para você é legal no celular.
Você consegue, por exemplo, expandir o
tamanho para ver a pergunta que aparece
na tela.
A maioria tá vendo do celular, pelo que
eu tô vendo aqui. Luciano, Vilma,
Ivan, corretor Ângelo.
Eh, vocês que estão vendo pelo celular,
vocês estão vendo do link do celular,
né? Ou vocês não prestaram atenção qual
que era o link? Porque tem dois links.
Eh, já tem há um mês ou mais que a gente
tá fazendo com dois links, um link para
celular e um link para computador barra
eh TV. Ok. Ótimo. Obrigado. Corretor.
Ângelo me avisou aqui que dá para
ampliar. Sim.
OK.
Ótimo. Tá. Qualquer coisa, se tiver
algum problema, vocês me avisam, tá? Por
favor. Bem, vamos começar aqui.
Pergunta: "Olá, doutor. Sou de Portugal.
Estive em Portugal aí no começo de
dezembro. Gostei muito da minha viagem,
apesar de ter sido curta, pro Congresso
Saúde Integrativa de Porto.
Então,
abraço para você aí de Portugal. Tenho
Herne de ato e tenho sempre muita azia,
até mesmo a beber água, principalmente à
noite ao deitar. Existe algum suplemento
que pode ajudar?
Bem, existe dois mecanismos para R
deato. Você tem um problema mecânico,
que pode ser uma, por exemplo,
uma questão aí de deslocamento, né? Uma
hér que a gente chama de deslizamento.
E tem as héras de ato que não tem
deslizamento, que o problema é mais e no
esfter mesmo, tá?
Então, a questão principal é você
começar a elevar a cabeceira da cama em
30 a 45º à noite. Tem gente que coloca
tijolo, né, na parte superior da cama,
né, no apoio superior da cama.
Então, deixe esse
aclíve, né, de 30 a 45º
e 20 deitar logo após as refeições.
E a boa parte do pessoal que tem refluxo
é por questões aí de falta de ácido no
estômago e não por excesso. Então é
imediato, seja ela por deslizamento ou
seja por deficiência do esfíncter.
É interessante você experimentar, tá,
doses baixas do cloridrato de betaína
com pepsina. Então você pode começar a
tomar 200 mg de coridade de betaína nas
refeições com 200 mg de pepsina. Se não
tiver desconforto,
eh, você pode aumentar a dose para 400
mg de betaína com 400 mg de pepsina.
Então, eh, vale a pena fazer esse teste
comodidade betaína.
Outra coisa que pode ajudar é usar o
licorice DGL, né, que é o alcass sem o o
a parte do ácido glicirísico, né, que é
aquilo que dá aumento de pressão. Então
o licorice DGL tá utilizando que ele é
um regulador de acidez e também
anti-inflamatório paraa mucosa.
Você pode estar tomando então esse DGL
ricorice 20 minutos antes das refeições
por algumas semanas para ajudar a
cicatrizar a irritação.
A melatonina também tem efeito
antirefluxo, além de ter efeito
antioxidante e indutor do sono. Então,
vale a pena tomar de 3 a 5 mg antes de
deitar.
E também existe o alginato. Alginato ele
faz o mecanismo de barreira para evitar
o refluxo. Então você pode tá tomando
alginato de cálcio à noite antes de
deitar também.
Elimin leite derivados, elimite elimine
o glúten, porque esses dois aí eles
causam problemas aí de refluxo, OK?
Cuidado com as gorduras artificiais,
cuidado com os alimentos
ultraprocessados.
faz o teste de hipocloridria, né,
tomando bicarbonato e vê quanto tempo
demora para você arrotar.
Alguns casos, você tiver muita
inflamação no esôfago por conta do
refluxo, vale a pena usar o prazol por
um tempo.
Usar o prazol aí por uma um período de
até 8 semanas, tá? Também é uma opção.
OK? e fazem endoscopia para avaliar
a extensão dessa energúrgico,
pode ter que fazer alguma cirurgia.
Doutor Alan, tudo bem? Queria fazer uso
de fermentados para saúde intestinal,
pois tenho ele preso. Deve ser intestino
preso, né? O senhor teria alguma
indicação melhor forma ou marca para
uso?
Olha, tem vários cementados. Você pode
estar utilizando o kefir. Existe o kefir
de água, existe o kefir de leite, existe
o kefir de leite de coco. Quefira seria
uma das melhores opções. Você pode obter
lá
os grânulos, né, do kefir através de
doação ou através de compra.
Existe também possibilidade, se você faz
aquele iogurte eterno, né, iogurte
que você vai renovando em casa, o
iogurte natural que você faz em casa.
Você pode utilizar também
repolho fermentado, por exemplo, ou
outros vegetais fermentados também, uma
boa, né? chucrute, que é o repolho
fermentado, ou qualquer vegetal
fermentado.
Você pode usar também o combuchá, né,
que é chá fermentado. Você pode utilizar
o quinchi, que é soja fermentada, que é,
aliás, quinchi é o existe o natô, que é
soja fermentada e o qu não é soja
fermentada, é outro alimento fermentado
que é da culinária
coreana, tá? Então você pode usar o
quinchi, você pode usar picles
fermentado,
OK?
Então todos esses são opções aí de
fermentado
e o chucrute especialmente ele é bom
paraa prisão de ventre, tá?
Se você for usar o combuch, toma cuidado
que tem marcas que eles colocam muito
açúcar
e se você tiver resistência a insulina
pode ser um problema.
Eu sempre começo com os fermentados,
porções de áreas pequenas, cerca de uma
colher de sopa antes das refeições
principais para que seu intestino possa
se adaptar gradualmente. OK?
Questão de marca não é bem o caso, né?
que geralmente você consegue se
fermentado de doação,
né? H,
não tenho uma marca específica para
recomendar, mas o mais interessante é
você ver qual desses vegetais aí que
você se adapta melhor, tá? se é o
quinchi, se é o cobux chá, se é o quefir
de leite, se é o quefir de água de coco,
se é o quefir de leite de coco, se é
iogurte, aquele iogurte eterno, né, que
você vai só renovando, tá? Aí tem que
dar uma olhada nisso aí.
Comecei na glicina taurina.
À noite tomo chá blue calme da pura vida
para dormir e durmo bem. entre os dois
dá uma dose taurina de 700 mg diária.
Essa dose é adequada? Sim, é uma dose
adequada. Tratos teatose, resistência
insulina com alimentação, hiperberina,
sirimarina e cúrcuma. Não, tá legal isso
aí, tá? Essa dose de taurina pode até
ser aumentada, não há nenhum problema. A
literatura fala de 2 a 3 g diário de
taurina, tá? Então, nenhum problema com
essa dose. Aí
a taurina tem várias atividades
interessantes. Ela vai ajudar no fígado,
vai ajudar no cérebro, vai ajudar no
coração. Ela tem ação importante de
melhorar a sensibilidade à insulina.
Ela modula a ação do gabo, ou seja, ela
aumenta a efetividade do
neurotransmissor calmante gaba.
Então é bem legal a taurina, tá? E é
muito seguro, tá? Então você pode estar
utilizando doses maiores,
pode ir aumentando aos poucos, OK?
Tem estudos internacionais que mostram
segurança até com 6 g, tá? Mas eu não
recomendo chegar nessa dose não, porque
vai ficar inclusive muito caro. O
protocolo com a Beberina, siri marina e
cúcuma tá bom.
E
então o que você tá fazendo tá
direitinho. Parabéns. Tá só experimenta
até aumentar a dose da taurina se for
necessário.
Doutor, quando se atinge um bom nível de
B12, D3, tem que dar uma pausa. Não
necessariamente. Você pode estar só
reduzindo dose.
Qual periodicidade de exames de
controle, né? Então não é necessário,
tá? Por exemplo, se tava tomando 10.000
de vitamina D, digamos que a sua
vitamina D foi pra 60 ou para 80, aí
você pode estar reduzindo para entre 2 a
5.000 por dia. A B12 estava tomando 1
mg, aí foi para, sei lá, 100 de B12. Aí
você pode estar reduzindo a B12 para 200
microg por dia, que dá 0,2 mg, por
exemplo, tá? seria essa conduta.
A vitamina D, ela tem uma variação muito
grande. Se você for uma pessoa mais
magra, a tendência é você ter que baixar
a dose da vitamina D de 10.000 1000 para
2000 em pouco tempo. Se você tiver mais
gordura corporal, essa vitamina D vai
ficar diluída no na gordura e aí ela vai
demorar mais tempo para aumentar e
geralmente a dose de manutenção também é
maior, tá?
Controle você faz no começo, a cada 3
meses. Depois que você tiver mais
habituada, você passa a fazer de seis em
se meses e até pode até pensar em fazer
de 12 em 12 meses depois de um tempo,
tá? Depois do primeiro ano,
mantém então sua vitamina D entre 60 e
80 e a B12 entre 800 e 1000 mais ou
menos. Tá bom?
Tenho conseguido controlar o refluxo e
aia por conta da herne de usando vinagre
de maçã e dieta.
Porém, quando fjo um pouco da dieta,
como agora no final do ano, tem dias que
sinto tais sintomas. A pergunta seria:
nesses dias, devo pausar o vinagre para
restabelecer mucosa inflamada? Sim, é
uma boa ideia isso aí, tá? Uma boa
pergunta. É uma boa ideia.
Então você
pode tá fazendo esse intervalo, sim,
não há nenhum problema. E se você não
sentir nenhuma desconforto com vinagre
de maçã voltando paraa dieta boa, você
pode manter o vinagre de maçã nesse
período que a dieta tiver boa.
Então, nesse momento que você tá agora,
que você teve um abuso aí com a
alimentação, o foco tem que ser em
restaurar mucosa. Então, comer alimentos
antiinflamatórios,
evitar os gatilhos que você já conhece,
que te dá o refluxo, a queimação, aia,
né? Pode usar aliglutamina, pode usar
colágeno hidrolizado para ajudar a
cicatrizar a mucosa, pode usar também,
né, o corebiome, probióticos.
Então, toda vez que você sair aí da
dieta normal sua e passar uma dieta
ruim, sim, você pode fazer esse
intervalo aí o na no vinagre de maçã.
Cara, tô impressionado com barulho que
será que essa janela aqui tá perdendo a
varidade, né?
Não tô entendendo esse barulho essa
janela aqui não.
Doutor, é verdade se deixar o feijão
germinar além de diminuir estamina
aumenta a dal? Sim, sim. É uma boa. Se
você puder comer brotos, é muito bom,
tá? Seja feijão, seja qualquer outro
alimento germinado, tá? Então essa
germinação vai reduzir de forma
significativa os antinutrientes, vai
reduzir fitato, tanino, melhora a
biodisponibilidade,
aumenta os compostos bioativos,
antioxidantes,
né? Esses brotos tem bastante
polifenóis interessantes. Por exemplo,
broto de brócolis tem bastante
sulforafano, né? Que é excelente paraa
saúde, tem ação de câncer.
Então, a questão de aumento de D, eu não
lembro de ter lido uma literatura
falando que aumenta D, tá? Eh, agora com
certeza
e reduz eh qualquer desconforto
abdominal que você tiver por conta de
fermentação que tem no feijão, por
exemplo.
Eu não tenho essa informação clara que a
germinação vai aumentar o DA,
OK? Mas sim, é uma boa você fazer a
germinação.
Depois eu dou uma olhada nesse assunto,
tá?
Hã,
com mais calma, mas eu realmente eu não
lembro de ter visto um artigo falando
disso.
Boa noite. Por gentileza, o que você me
recomenda por em um pré-treino
manipulado? Tem várias coisas dá para
colocar, né? seria o principal pilar se
você não tiver sensibilidade, se você
não tiver problema com cafeína,
se você tiver problema com cafeína, usa
até acrina que é mais caro, mas dá menos
problema que agitação, dado, café.
Então, ou cafeína ou teacrina, a
betaalanina que vai ter o efeito de
tamponamento, aumenta os níveis aí de
carnosina nos músculos e vai aumentar
tua tolerância ao exercício, né? vai ter
esse efeito tampão. Arginina ou
citronina vai aumentar a vaso dilatação,
mas melhorar o seu desempenho pelo
aumento do fluxo sanguíneo.
A taurina para reduzir fadiga.
Pode pôr também uma creatina nesse
pré-treino. Não necessariamente tem que
ser antes do treino, mas se você quiser
juntar
doses baixas de vitamina C como
antioxidante, porque se você põ uma dose
alta pode atrapalhar o seu ganho
muscular, né? Se você tiver como
objetivo hipertrofia,
você pode pôr também um extrato de chá
verde para combater o estresse
oxidativo.
É interessante, tá?
Ã, seria esses daí que que eu colocaria,
tá?
Na verdade, se você pensar bem, todos
esses elementos não são obrigatórios
você tomar antes do treino, a não ser a
cafeína, né? Mas é interessante sim, se
você tiver uma consistência, né, de
tomar isso daí sempre, vale a pena usar
essa combinação. Então vamos lá de novo.
Creatina, betalanina, extrato chá verde,
vitamina C até uns 500 mg num passarinho
de 500 mg, argilina ou citrulina na
faixa de 500 mg a 1 g. Cafeína na faixa
de 200 mg,
tá? Betalanina você pode colocar aí uns
2 g, tá? no pré-treino seria isso aí, tá
bom?
Sobre esquizofrenia, existe algum estudo
sobre uso de suplementos para ajudar a
pessoa que tem esquizofrenia? Vamos lá,
boa pergunta, tá? Quem estudou muito
isso no passado foi o Dr. Abrn Hoffer,
que foi um dos precursores da medicina
ortomolecular. OK?
Hã, vamos falar for branhofrer, que ele
recomendava a niacina ou a niacinamida,
né, também conhecido como nicotinamida
em altas doses.
Existe uma revisão que foi feito na
Universidade de Manchester.
Essa revisão foram 18 ensaios clínicos.
Eles utilizaram vitaminas B, o complexo
Bem altas doses. Isso também o Aber
Hoffer utilizava
B6, B8 e B12, OK? B6 é a piridoxina, B12
é a cobalamina, seja metilcobalamina,
hidroxicobalamina.
A B8 eu não me lembro qual que é porque
ela não é uma vitamina B padrão, tá? Mas
puseram, será que é a colina? Agora não
lembro, mas enfim, nesse estudo foi B6,
B8 e B12.
e introduziram isso junto com o
tratamento antipsicótico. Isso a Branho
Rofre também fazia. Então ele não tirava
o antipsicótico. Na verdade ele
reduzindo muito lentamente, muito
lentamente o antipsicótico.
Então isso reduz de uma forma bem
significativa o sintoma de
esquizofrenia.
Você
pode estar colocando também a vitamina
C, pode estar colocando a vitamina D,
pode estar colocando ômega-3,
pode estar colocando vários probióticos
que ajudam na parte mental também,
especialmente
raminosos, né, o lactobacíos raminosos,
que tem um efeito cerebral.
Então essa é uma boa combinação, tá? Tem
casos, por exemplo, se beneficia usando
zinco, aí teria que fazer um estudo para
saber se tem deficiência de zinco, tá?
Então, seria essas dicas que eu tô te
passando aí. Dá uma lida no livro do
Abram Hoffer. Tem uma edição mais nova.
Deixa eu ver se eu acho aqui que eu, se
eu não me engano, eu tenho esse livro na
minha conta da Amazon.
Deixa eu olhar aqui rapidinho.
Ã ah, deixa eu entrar no meu Kindle.
Acho que é mais fácil. Tô olhando na
Amazon, mas a Kind é melhor, né?
Deixa eu ver se eu consigo entrar na
minha conta aqui do Kindle.
Não, esse aqui é Amazon, é Kindle.
Pera aí. aqui.
Bem, deixa eu ver se eu acho aqui.
Aí eu divido a tela com vocês. Acho que
é mais fácil procurar pelo Hofer, né? Ab
Hofer.
Aqui, ó. Achei.
Deixa eu dividir a tela com vocês aqui.
Deixa eu mudar aqui. Ã,
stop screen.
Share screen.
Olha aí. Tá. Não sei se tá dando para
ver. Deixa eu ampliar um pouquinho aqui.
Esses são os livros que eu tenho do
Abram Hoffer. OK.
Ã, tá aqui, tá vendo aqui?
Tratamentocular da esquizofrenia.
Esse livro é bem legal.
Agora não lembro se esse que é o antigo.
Eu acho que o mais novo é esse aqui, ó.
Nias in the real story. Se eu não me
engano. É esse livro
que é o
o mais recente. Deixa eu ver aqui.
Table of contents. Cadê o cover aqui?
Tá. Eu acho que esse livro é o mais
recente.
Deixa eu ver se tem aqui. É a segunda
edição.
Bem, dá uma olhada no livro do Abonn
Hoffer, tá? Que vale a pena, tá? O nome
dele tá aqui, ó. Tá? Abn Hofer. Aqui, ó.
Deixa eu ampliar um pouco mais aqui.
Pera aí.
Será que dá para ampliar aqui? Não sei.
É, não tá dando para ampliar não, mas
acho que tá dando para ler, né? Tá.
Abram Hofer. E não é Abraham não. Esse
nome aqui só tem o Abram Hofer com dois
FS aqui. Bem, deixa eu continuar. Vamos
lá.
Ah, vamos colocar
stop screen.
Share screen. Vamos continuar aqui.
Me fala sobre o que o colosso bovino
pode ajudar.
É, o colostro bovino é bem interessante.
O que que é o colostro? É o primeiro
leite produzido pela vaca ou pela
espécie mamífera após o parto, né?
Geralmente a gente usa o colostro bovino
e não o colostro humano, né? Mas é o
primeiro leite produzido pela vaca após
do parto pode ajudar em três grandes
áreas. Primeiro, e fortalece o sistema
imune porque tem altíssimas
concentrações de imunoglobulinas,
tá? Que é 50 a 300 vezes maior que o
leite maduro, né? O leite que não é o
primeiro. Tem lactoferrina que modula
células de defesa, linfócitos e
macrófagos. É excelente para restaurar a
integridade da barreira intestinal.
Previne a questão do intestino
hiperpermeável, também ajuda a tratar.
promove também regeneração da mucosa,
tem componente antiinflamatório,
melhora a recuperação muscular, o
desempenho físico,
tá? Então tem essas várias vantagens aí.
Pode também ajudar na recuperação de
problemas respiratórios. Recentemente eu
vi um estudo falando de prevenção de
infecção urinária com lactoferrina
por causa da ação imunomoduladora,
tá? Então é particularmente valioso para
pessoas imunocomprometidas, idosos,
atletas sobre treinamento intenso e para
qualquer um que tem o liquidate. OK?
Melhor tratamento para CB. Uma pessoa da
família está sofrendo há meses, já fez
endoscopia,
irá fazer colonoscopia. O médico
orientou passar pelo nutricionista
que modificou a dieta. Porém,
estufamento, desconforto persistem mesmo
com o uso do dexilã. Na verdade, o
dexilan ele vai aumentar o o
estufamento, tá? O desconforto. Vocês às
vezes se confundem.
O Dexilan, na verdade, ele não trata
Cibo, tá? Ele, na verdade, ele causa
Cibo.
Não sei qual foi a informação que
passaram para você,
mas o dexilã ele é um bloqueador potente
da acidez de estômago. Então, ele é uma
causa de cibo e não um tratamento de
cibo. Ele vai tratar úlcera dodenal,
úlcera gástrica, gastrite intensa. Isso
ele vai tratar. Agora ele provoca cibo
com frequência, tá?
Então o tratamento do cibo é com
antibióticos, seja naturais ou seja com
antibióticos de farmácia. E o
antibiótico mais conhecido para Cboir, a
refaximina,
é o padrão ouro. É um antibiótico caro
que ainda tem que ser trazido importado.
Eu não sei porque que até hoje eles não
nacionalizaram esse remédio. O ciclo
geralmente são 14 dias e custa por volta
de R$ 1.000. tratar o cibo não é barato
e existe muita recidiva. Então é
importante depois de tomar rifaximina
tomar os antibióticos naturais,
antifúnicos naturais, antimicrobianos
naturais por até uns 3 meses, tá?
porque tem muita, muita recidiva.
E depois que tomar os antibióticos
naturais, depois desses 90 dias aí, ou
seja, 14 dias de faximina, mais 60 de
antibiótico natural, aí depois entra com
probióticos, tá? A terceira opção aí são
os probióticos, terceira medida em
sequência.
É importante muitas vezes investigar uma
utilidade intestinal. Tem muitas pessoas
que tibo
porque tem um problema motor, tá? Seja
gast gastroparesia, né? Que é o estômago
que tem dificuldade de se movimentar,
ou pode ser uma obstrução anatômica,
tá? Então tem que investigar isso aí.
A dieta,
muitas vezes você tem que fazer uma
dieta low de map, que é aquela dieta com
baixos fermentáveis ou uma dieta baixa
estamina. Às vezes nem um nem outro. Se
for um caso muito grave de cíbo, tem que
fazer aquela dieta alimentar, tomando
como se fosse aquela alimentação interal
por uns 15 dias para dar um reset no
intestino.
Prosinéticos, depois que você tiver
melhorando da do cibo, é importante
entrar com probió, desculp probióticos,
não, procinéticos. É o caso, por
exemplo, gengibre, é o caso do baixa
dosagem.
Ah, existe o trifala que é da
medicinaveda também que ajuda, tá bom?
Entrar também com bloqueadores aí de
biofilme, né, como NAC, né? Só que o NAC
tem que com cuidado que tem muita gente
que tem intolerância ao NC, certo?
Então tem que tomar um certo cuidado.
Então, lactobacilos para quem tem CBO
não é o primeiro remédio, tá? O terceiro
remédio nessa sequência que nós
conversamos. Eu tenho vários vídeos no
canal sobre esse assunto. Dá uma olhada
lá.
Doutor Alan, por gentileza, a oxitocina
antagoniza com prolactina em homens? Se
sim, em caso de um paciente com
prolactinoma, será que a oxitocina
sublingual poderia ser usada para
substituir a cabergolina
no controle da produção de prolactina?
Eu não faria essa troca primeiro porque
a cabergolina é um remédio muito seguro,
tá? Todas as vezes que eu usei, nunca me
arrependi, tá? Um remédio bastante
tranquilo,
é só saber utilizar, começar com 0,5 mg,
não aumentar dose de uma vez. É um
remédio muito eficiente e não vejo razão
de não utilizar porque eu nunca vi
efeito colateral
importante, tá? Dentro do meu
conhecimento, eu não nunca vi pelo menos
informação
que a oxitocina seja eficiente para
fazer isso, tá?
para baixar prolactina,
até porque as vias são diferentes, né? A
oxitocina,
ela tem um mecânigação diferente do
da prolactina. São receptores
diferentes. Agora não sei onto se você
viu isso especificamente, mas eu eu
sempre tratei hiperpolactinemia
com cabergolina, nunca me arrependi, tá?
O oxitocina, na verdade, eh, quando teve
muito hype, uns 5 se anos atrás, eu
utilizei, para falar a verdade, eu não
gostei muito dos efeitos oxitocina. Eu
acho um ativo assim, nunca vi ninguém
mudar a vida por conta de oxitocina.
Agora tem colega que fala que oxitocina
dá muito efeito, né? Geralmente a gente
usa para mulheres que têm baixo libido,
que não responde à testosterona ou que
não tem indicação de fazer testosterona.
para homem também que tá com baixo
libido pode ser utilizado, mas
sinceramente a minha experiência
comitocina não é das melhores, tá? Na
teoria muito lindo, na prática eu não
vejo ter esse resultado maravilhoso,
não.
Tá? Não vejo razão de não usar
cabergolina. Se você tiver mais alguma
informação
eh sobre a cabegolina, se teve problema
com a begegolina, por isso que você não
quer utilizar, tá? Tá? Então me conta
isso daí.
Como identificar ou testar ômega-3 com
ester e sem ester.
Aí não tem muito jeito de você testar
isso não. Você tem que olhar o rótulo,
né?
Eh, tem que acreditar no rótulo.
Se não tiver escrito triglicerídio
ou TG, vai ser um estra etílico. OK?
A forma em triglicerídeos é mais cara, é
menos comum,
então tem que ficar muito atento ao
rótulo.
Aquela história de colocar o ômega-3 na
geladeira, se congelar é ruim.
Aquilo é mais em relação à qualidade
geral do ômega-3. Aquilo não tem nada a
ver com o fato ser trigliceríde ou ser
ester, tá?
Então aquele teste da geladeira não é
para isso.
Se não tiver escrito com todas as letras
TG ou triglicerídeo, você pode
considerar que é um ester, tá?
Existe mais de uma certificação
internacional, tá? Eu eu
escutei de algumas pessoas aí que não
iam comprar ômega-3 do biobalance porque
não tinha o IFOS. O IFO não é a única
certificação, tem o USP também, tá? E a
certificação nem sempre quer dizer que o
produto que não tem necessariamente é
ruim, porque essas empresas
certificadoras às vezes cobram muito
caro da marca e eles às vezes não querem
pagar o valor, tá? Então, por exemplo,
eu mesmo recomendo a creatina que tem um
selo creapuri, mas tem creatinas boas no
mercado que não tem o selo, tá?
Dr. Alan, por bondade,
gostaria de saber se todos os
brasileiros têm áscares lubricovóides e
se é verdade que elas se alimentam de
magnésio.
Cara, eu tive uma conversa ao telefone
com a Dra. Maria Emília Gadelha Serra,
né, que é minha amiga. A gente ficou
mais de meia hora no telefone discutindo
essa questão de parasita,
porque existe essa corrente muito forte
na medicina integrativa, que os
parasitas são os grandes vilões, né, que
causa um monte de doença, inclusive
câncer.
Eu não concordo com a visão de muita
gente, inclusive da própria Maria
Emília, de que os parasitas são esses
demônios aí.
E o fato de ter vários antiparasitários
que têm ação de câncer causa confusão na
cabeça das pessoas, porque elas pensam
que por
pelo fato do antiparasitário atuar no
câncer, então o câncer é um parasita.
Tem três parasitas na literatura que de
fato aumentam o risco de câncer, tá? Um
deles é o
tem um que é só da desses três,
praticamente os três são da África, tá?
tem um que causa câncer de bexiga, que é
o hematóbium. Eh, agora não lembro se
primeiro nome dele era se era, esqueci
agora. Mas enfim, e essa teoria do do
parasita como causa do câncer é uma
teoria que
eu tenho muita, eu fiz uma revisão
literatura esses poucos dias atrás
tentando descobrir alguma coisa que
realmente desse respaldo ao pessoal que
fala isso, mas eu não consegui achar.
Eles me mandaram uma coisa da da CIA
falando lá, um documento da CIA de 1951
falando que os russos estavam estudando
que os parasitas poderiam ser causas
de câncer, mas isso já foi refutado, tá?
Não é porque existe uma teoria da
conspiração em relação isso, não. Mas
respondendo a sua pergunta, nem todo
mundo tem áscares,
tá? A prevalência, ela é preocupante em
algumas regiões.
Os dados epidemiológicos mostram que em
áreas de pobreza extrema e ausência de
saneamento em algumas áreas do norte e
nordeste, a prevalência pode ser muito
alta mesmo, 83 até 94%.
Especialmente comunidades ribeirinhas lá
da Amazônia.
Ã,
essa história do magnésio aí, eu não
encontrei isso na literatura.
o os pares dealimento do que você come,
tá? Do conteúdo intestinal, dos
nutrientes que você come. Então, o
magnésio pode estar entrando no meio
desse pacote aí, mas não é que não quer
dizer que o parasita vai comer mais
magnésio do desproporcionalmente aos
outros nutrientes, tá? Então essa
história que vai ser mais o magnésio do
que outros minerais, eu não conheço essa
história não,
tá? Então não é que ele vai comer vários
nutrientes, incluindo o magnésio, mas o
magnésio aí não é um destaque.
Olá, Dra. Lan. A rotina 150 mg é um bom
suplemento para circulação e
fortalecimento das veias. A rotina é sim
um excelente suplemento paraa
circulação. É um bioflavonoide,
atua no fortalecimento capilares dos
vasos sanguíneos, regula a peribilidade,
aumenta a resistência capilar, inibe a
agregação plaquetária, reduz risco de
trombose,
de doenças cardiovasculares no geral,
tem propriedade anti-inflamatória
potente, combate a inflamação crônica,
estimula a produção de colágeno,
tá muito bom para prevenção. em
tratamento de varizes, hemorróidas
e a dose é 150 mg duas vezes ao dia.
E é muito importante associar isso a uma
atividade física regular, a uma boa
hidratação e alimentação adequada,
assim, alimentos processados, tá?
Assisti uma entrevista no canal do
Fernando Betete com a Dra. Adriana
Mendes. Ela diz que o ferro não m
proveniente de suplementos e até
injetáveis age com metal tóxico do
organismo entupindo os receptores. Eu
acho que nem foi ela que veio com essa
história. Acho foi Lai Ribeiro. Falou de
um suplemento nos Estados Unidos chamado
glucoferrin. Ela não mencionou o estudo
sobre esse assunto, só relatou sua
experiência clínica, inclusive com ela
mesma e com a filha.
Olha, cansei de usar ferro.
bisglicato.
Cansei de usar o fisiogen, que é um
ferro com vitamina C e funciona assim,
tá? O que acontece, se a pessoa tiver
uma anemia muito intensa,
aí é importante começar com injetável
endovenoso, tá? Mas funciona sim. Os
suplementos de ferro que eu uso, que não
são m, funcionam sim.
Agora, essa história que ela falou em
relação ao ferro atuar como metal tóxico
em excesso, com certeza. Por isso que a
ferritina
em grandes quantidades é ruim pro
organismo, tá? O ferro livre ele provoca
a chamada reação de fenton, tá? Que é um
tipo de estresse oxidativo bem
importante
e pode acontecer com suplementação
excessiva, né? Mas aí eu acho que nem
isso tá falando, né?
Tem gente que toma ferro injetável sem
precisar. Já cansei de ver isso.
Agora esse glucoferrin que ela tá
falando aí,
ela tá dizendo o quê? Bem ou mal do
glucoferrin? Porque esse glucoferrin eu
nunca utilizei, mas é um ferro não M,
tá? Que seria o que ela tá criticando
aí. Vocês
têm que estar sempre vendo os exames, a
ferritina, a saturação de transferrina,
o ferro sérico para determinar se é
necessário realmente o uso do ferro, tá?
Porque tem pessoas, por exemplo, que tem
a ferritina alta
e que é por inflamação, tem nada a ver
com o excesso de ferro, ok?
Agora, como eu falei, na minha
experiência, essa suplementação com
ferro não m, por exemplo, o fisiogênio é
ferro não m, eu vejo o resultado sim,
pode demorar alguns meses às vezes para
ter resultado, mas eu vejo o resultado
sim, tá? Então não sei porque que ela tá
falando isso. Eu acho que se eu não me
engano lá em Ribeiro falava essa
história também.
Qual a sua opinião sobre para paciente
portador de helicobter nãoicobir? Não,
esquericha, perdão, multiresistente,
já foi internada para tratamento
antibiótico endovenoso, relatado no
exame do antibiograma
e outros por via oral e a bactéria ainda
continua e pior aumentou mais ainda no
exame de cultura.
Desde a infância tem bichiga hiperativa
e o médico receitou mirabegrona 25 mg
dia, né? Que é o MBETC.
Ah,
minha opinião, você tá querendo saber o
como é faria para tratar esse paciente?
É isso
aí. O problema não é o antibiótico tá
usando, né? O problema é que essa pessoa
está tendo uma recidível muito frequente
da da bactéria. Então tem que ver se não
tem obstrução mecânica, se não tem algum
problema na bexiga, se não tem alguma
situação de esvaziamento da bexiga
inadequado. Não sei se essa pessoa fez
estudo dinâmico, que é muito importante
para ver se não tem uma bexiga flácida,
né? é uma bexiga neurogênica,
ah, reflexa, que pode estar atrapalhando
osamente da bexiga.
Ah, então a questão normalmente o
pessoal sempre tá pensando que ah, quem
tem infecção é porque a infecção não
sarou totalmente. Geralmente não é isso.
Geralmente afecção sara, mas ela volta
muito rápido porque a pessoa tem fatores
predisponentes que pode ser uma bexiga
que não esvazia direito, como eu acabei
de falar, que pode ser também pedra na
bexiga, pedra dos rins, né? Então tem
várias razões aí para as pessoas terem
infecções urinárias de repetição. Em
mulher especialmente é muito comum
algumas mulheres tem uma uma questão
congênita
eh com a o epitélio, né, o orotélio
que não tem aquela aqueles pelinhos que
ajudam a eliminar as bactérias, tá?
Então elas acabam tendo mais facilidade
de ter infecção urinária, além da
uretrafeminense muito curta e facilitar
a ascensão das bactérias paraa bexiga,
tá?
Então tem que ver se de fato geralmente
não é bactéria multiente, geralmente é
recidiva, tá? Ah, e quando tem muita
recidiva, às vezes as bactérias começam
a ficar resistentes também, tá? Tem
estudos recentes que mostram que
combinações com mecilinã e cefotaxima
para certos tipos de esteríco ali
multiresistente, né? E a fosfomicina
também, que é um antibiótico facilmente
encontrado aí em farmácia, pode ajudar a
combater essas infecções.
Tem que dar uma olhada no na questão
imunológica, se eu não tenho um
comprometimento imunológico nessa
paciente,
ver se a microbiota intestinal tá OK ou
você não foi devastada poros
antibióticos utilizados anteriormente,
vê se não tá ingerindo muito alimento
inflamatório,
vê os níveis de vitamina D, de zinco.
E essa bexiga hiperativa aí pode ser
simplesmente a bexiga inflamada pela
infecção. Aí pode não ser exatamente uma
bijiga hiperativa clássica. A gente só
chama de bichiga hiperativa quando a
pessoa de fato tem ã não tem uma
explicação muito óbvia para
hiperatividade, porque qualquer infecção
urinária na bexiga provoca
hiperatividade, tá? Então tem que ver se
não é isso aí. as infecções provoca
hiperatividade e nesse caso a gente não
chama de bichiga hiperativa.
Como eu falei, existe estudos aí usando
a lactoferrina para evitar infecção na
área de repetição. Tem um cran berry que
pode ser utilizado, tem
o a demanose para prevenção. Tem gente
que usa o um antiparasitário para isso
também, para aumentar o sistema imune,
né, que é o ascaridin. OK?
Então tem que tá investigando com muito
cuidado porque que essa pessoa tá tendo
infecção de repetição, tá?
Doutor, vi um vídeo seu de 7 anos atrás
falando sobre Cardarine. Sim, é verdade.
Eu fiz vídeo sobre Sarm e SERMS.
anos atrás.
Já fiz um ciclo de 60 dias com ela há 6
meses atrás e vi que meu VO2 máximo, né,
que é capacidade respiratória aumentou
bem. Consegui ter melhoras no endurance,
porém fiquei com medo de fazer novos
ciclos, pois vi alguns especialistas
dizendo que tinha possível causa de
câncer pela sua experiência. Eu não
tenho tanta experiência com Cardarini
porque eu utilizei por um tempo, depois
eles proibiram no Brasil e para mim você
é o melhor médico que fala no YouTube.
Obrigado. Esse modulador seletivo é
confiável
e realmente tem esse efeito colateral.
Mesmo depois de 6 meses, é possível
fazer um novo ciclo com ele, visando a
melhora de VO2.
Bem, a classificação do Cardarini não é
se sarm ou serm, tá? Na verdade, ele é
oficialmente
um agonista PPAR delta.
O problema também é que todos esses
peptídios aí, eles são underground,
tem muito pouco estudo de segurança.
Eu não usaria por tempos prolongados, eu
usaria por períodos curtos.
Tem alguns estudos em animais que
mostram sim problemas, né, formação de
tumores em vários órgãos. Geralmente
eles usam doses muito altas, né, nos
cobaias. Então tem que ser levado em
consideração isso, mas eu acho que não
vale o o risco benefício, tá? Você
provavelmente não é atleta profissional,
você muito provavelmente não vive disso,
né? Não ganha dinheiro para correr ou
para fazer qualquer esporte aí de
endurance.
Eu acho que não correria o risco de você
ter um tumor, mesmo que o risco seja
pequeno, tá? Então, nesses estudos de
animais teve tumor de fígado, tireoide,
língua, estômago, testículo. E aí a
UADA, né, que é aquela agência que
regula o uso de anabolizantes nos
esportes profissionais, proibiu isso aí,
né,
que é a agência mundial antidop.
Então, a gente não tem estudos clínicos
de longo prazo, né? Tá proibido no
Brasil, não é autorizado também nos
Estados Unidos.
Eu sinceramente não recomendo que você
continue utilizando, tá? Porque
provavelmente o uso que você tá usando é
recreativo, tá?
Para melhorar o VO2, você pode utilizar,
por exemplo, aquelas máscaras especiais,
né? correr com máscara ou não sei qual
que é a atividade que você faz é
corrida, mas tem aquela máscara especial
que simula a altitude, né? Eu acho que é
muito mais seguro você usar isso do que
usar cardine.
Você pode fazer uns treinos
intervalados, né? O hit, pode estar
utilizando coisema que é 10, carnitina,
citrulina, arginina, creatina.
Eh, eu acho que não justifica, tá?
Agora me diz aí se você tiver
acompanhando ao vivo se você é
esportista profissional ou se você é só
amador. Tá,
Dr. Alan, você conhece o medicamento
para osteoporose forte cteriparatida,
caneta.
Ele foi indicado por uma amiga de 79
anos, a mesma que toma hidrocortisona.
é caríssimo e ela terá que fazer um
pedido judicial porque ela não não deve
ter recurso, não é fornecido pela
farmácia do estado. Ele eficaz para
osteoporose. Quais são seus efeitos
colaterais? Sim, a teriparatida é
eficaz,
ela pode ajudar na questão da
osteoporose provocada pela
hidrocortisona.
é o único remédio que realmente forma
osso novo, aumentando a massa óssea,
diferente dos outros remédios que tem
por aí, como prolia, como os
bifosfonados,
tem uma melhora clínica observada entre
6 a 9 meses de tratamento.
Problema que é muito caro, né?
efeitos colaterais que são comentados
aí,
é tontura transitória, robô facial,
náusea, dor articular, esse tipo de
remédio não tem aquele problema necrose
de cabeça de fêmor ou de mandíbula que
tem os outros que eu mencionei,
mas é muito importante ela tá também, tá
utilizando cálcio, magnésio, boro,
silício, proteína adequada, vitamina D,
K2,
vitamina A também, zinco e cobre, tá?
Verificar tudo isso daí. Ã, então eu
acho que vale a pena utilizar sim, se
for considerar tudo o resto que eu
acabei de falar junto, tá?
Então esse é um remédio super caro, mas
que não tem os problemas que a gente
verificava com os outros aí que eu já
mencionei, né? Como é o caso do Prolia e
dos bifosfonados.
Hoje faço reposição hormonal com 1 ml de
testosterona por semana, deve ser o
espionato,
e 2 ml de masteron semanal.
No mundo maromba esse ciclo é
considerado bem baixo. É, no mundo
maromba não é um critério muito bom, tá?
Mas para mim tem sido incríveis
resultados.
Esse ciclo é possível manter ao longo
prazo, fazendo exames três vezes ao ano.
Olha,
deixa te falar, Ângelo. Eu acho que pra
maioria das pessoas, vamos ser bem
sincero aqui, não existe uso totalmente
seguro de anabolizante, tá? Para fins
estéticos, pelo menos, não é? Não tô nem
falando de anabolizante para pessoas com
sarcopenia ou com osteoporose, que eu já
usei em várias mulheres idosas. Isso
nunca me arrependi.
Porém, para uso estético,
a conclusão que eu cheguei depois de
muitos anos é que não existe uso seguro
estético, tá? Você pode ter um azar do
caramba, fazer só um ciclo e se ferrar.
É comum, não é? Muito incomum. Se você
fizer, sei lá, dois ciclos e parar, você
vai ter problema. A chance muito
pequena, tá? Agora, o que acontece que o
pessoal que faz ciclo é muito viciante,
tá? Questão da imagem corporal, porque
você faz um ciclo para o que acontece na
prática é que a grande maioria das
pessoas não tem disciplina para comer
direito, dormir direito, treinar direito
por períodos muito longos. Então você
faz o ciclo, você tem um ganho muito
grande, principalmente o primeiro ciclo,
aí você tem resultado, você fica viciado
no resultado. Você para de usar 80% do
que você ganhou, você perde. E aí isso
mexe muito com a cabeça. Aí você quer
fazer o segundo ciclo, quer fazer o
terceiro ciclo. Aí você começa a
conversar lá com os malucos lá e começa
a fazer
eh cruise e blast. Cruise blast. Aquele
pessoal que fica tomando dose alta e
altíssima. alta e altíssima. Fica
alternando. Saia dessa não vale a pena,
tá?
Não vale a pena, tá?
Eu acho que o risco é muito alto de você
ficar viciado no resultado. O vício não
é porque você vai ficar sentindo
eh eh sintoma de
eh como é que fala? De abstinência. Não
é isso. É que é porque a pessoa ela fica
viciada no resultado, tá?
Então existe esse risco sim,
supressão permanente do eixo potalamf
testículo. Você pode ficar, não sei qual
tua idade, mas você pode ficar
permanentemente
infértil,
ã, pode ter atrofia testicular
irreversível e você tem que ficar
tomando depois para sempre testosterona.
Eh, não sei se foi essa a motivação sua,
se no começo era reposição e depois você
mudou para doses um pouco maiores, né,
para ter desempenho.
Pode alterar muito perfil lipídico, pode
baixar muito HDL colesterol, aumentar
triglices, LDL, você pode ter efeito
negativo no coração, no fígado, tá?
O uso constante no masteron também não é
bom, tá? Apesar dele ser um agente
andurrogênico mais leve,
ele vai te gerar problemas também.
Então eu não faria isso, tá? Eu usaria
talvez 0,5 ml de cipionato por semana
entre 05 a ml, tá? nessa faixa aí, se
você de fato tiver problema com
testosterona, se você não tiver, pare
tudo, faça um TPC aí, um uma terapia pós
ciclo com clomifeno, né, com HCG,
tá bom? Pensa muito bem se tá fazendo
aí, cuidado.
Não é falso moralismo, pessoal, é custo
benefício.
Insulina cinco ou seis já é motivo de
atenção, não tá? Uma insulina excelente
se foi insulina de jejum. Agora tudo
depende, né? Tem gente que tem insulina
de cinco ou seis e tem glicemia
altíssima, né? Então é uma pessoa que já
tem falência pancreática. Aí é uma outra
situação. Então se você tem, por
exemplo, insulina 5 ou se a glicemia tá
200 ou 300, aí já é um diabete tipo 2
que teve falência de células beta
pancreática. Agora vamos dizer que a tua
insulina tá 5 ou se tua glicemia tá 80.
Aí tá perfeito, tá? OK.
Então, a insulina nesse número aí, se a
glicemia tiver acompanhando, tá ótimo.
Boa noite. Em um vídeo sobre vitamina C
de outro profissional que também
acompanho, ele explicou que a oxidação
da vitamina C no organismo pode causar
cálculos.
Não é bem oxidação, tá? É a, você talvez
tenha entendido errado, é a
metabolização da vitamina C em oxalato,
tá?
Não é então oxidação, é metabolismo ou
metabolização.
E que uma das principais causas dessa
oxidação é o fumo. Minha dúvida é parar
de fumar antes de começar a
suplementação com vitamina C. Resolve
essa oxidação pelo fumo ou o acúmulo de
anos fumando já é suficiente para
oxidação?
Bem, a vitamina C ela não é um grande
antioxidante, tá? Ela é muito útil sim
para ser uma estratégia, mas ela
isoladamente não é um grande
antioxidante. Ela tem um papel
importante no colágeno também, tá? Então
não vai resolver sozinho o estresse
oxidativo do fumo.
Se você vai parar de fumar, que eu
recomendo fortemente, tá? Você pode
suplementar a vitamina C com ou sem
fumo, mas o fator crítico aqui não é o
histórico de fumo, mas a dose de
vitamina C, né? Então, eh, fumante vai
ter mais necessidade de vitamina C,
então você teria necessidades maiores.
Aí seria interessante estar utilizando 1
gama quatro vezes ao dia, se você for
fumante e e reduzir essa frequência pela
metade do se você parar de fumar.
Olá, doutor. Consumir pipoca antes de
alimentos que dão alto pico glicêmico
seria uma estratégia para minimizar os
danos?
tem um pouco de fibra na pipoca. Isso
poderia ajudar a retardar a absorção de
glicose no intestino e atenuar aos picos
de açúcar no sangue.
Só que a própria pipoca é um alimento de
alto índice glicêmico. OK?
Quando você prepara pipoca
com,
por exemplo, tem exagerar no óleo, no
sal, no açúcar,
ela vai ter sim alguns polifenóis que
vai funcionar como freio glicêmico. Tem
as fibras que eu já comentei, mas o
efeito é modesto e ela ainda continua
sendo um alimento de alto índice
gliccêêmico.
Agora ela sozinha pipoca, ela não vai
ser um alimento que vai fazer muito
efeito de bloquear aí a questão aí do
alto pico glicêmico, não tá? Estratégia
mais importante seria você evitar o
máximo alimentos processados,
industrializados, cortar o açúcar,
alementos aí
ricos em xarope de milho, seria muito
mais importante, tá?
Então, fazendo uma analogia, você usar
pipoca para tentar reduzir índice
glicêmico, né, ou pico glicêmico, seria
como você tentar frear um carro, descer
numa montanha com freio de mão, né,
e quanto descer sem freios, tá?
enquanto que o melhor seria você não
descer tão rápido.
Bem, vamos pra próxima pergunta.
Boa noite. A farinha de mandioca pode
ser comparada à farinha refinada,
trazendo o mesmo prejuízo ou podemos
colocá-la no grupo de alimentos
saudáveis? Faz diferença a farinha de
mandioca grossa e fina?
Não, a farinha de mandioca é bem melhor
do que as farinhas refinadas, né? Se
você não comer excesso, você pode até
comer com moderação. Vai depender muito
do seu
ah nível aí de resistência ulínica, OK?
A maioria das farinhas refinadas tm alto
índice glicêmico,
são pobres em fibras. E a farinha de
mandioca,
além de ser isenta de glúten, ela tem um
índice glicêmico médio, tem mais fibras.
Então, se você não tiver,
digamos assim,
numa situação boa em atividade física,
tiver metabolicamente saudável, você
pode usar sim a farinha de mandioca. OK?
Lógico que tem pessoas que não podem
porque já estão com o diabetes mais
avançado, tá?
Uma coisa boa da farinha de mandioca que
ela tem minerais, tem potássio,
magnésio, ferro, manganês,
é uma fonte triptofano de vitamina B6
que vai ser
um
quaduvante aí para produção de
serotonina.
Ah, você pode usar tanto a a grossa
quanto a fina, tá? Não tem grande
diferença entre elas, não. Só lembrar de
usar com moderação, não exagerar e
associar com gorduras e proteínas para
diminuir mais ainda a absorção e
processamento desse carboidrato. Tá bom?
Para pessoas que vão se consultar com
você online, qual câmera tecnologia
recomenda para transmissão e para ter
grande aproveitamento?
É, na verdade a câmera aí não vai ser um
grande pedimento, não, tá? Mas se você
puder escolher, escolhe uma câmera que
tenha pelo menos uma resolução HD ou
Full HD de 1080p, tá? um webcam
que vai ser uma imagem nítida e clara o
suficiente. Se você tá falando isso
porque você tem que mostrar a pele na
consulta, uma coisa assim,
tem que ser uma câmera boa, né? E a mais
importante ainda do que a câmera boa,
tem que ter uma boa eliminação, porque
não adianta ter uma câmera 1080p, você
tá num ambiente escuro que não dá para
ver nada, tá?
Agora, realmente, a qualidade de áudio é
muito mais importante que a quidade de
vídeo para teleconsulta, tá? Geralmente
não é um um bom meio para fazer uma
consulta dermatológica. Aí é melhor
fazer presencial.
Se é isso, tá pensando. Não sei se é
isso.
Importante também manter a câmera limpa,
tá? que às vezes ela tá com gordura em
cima e atrapalha muito a visualização.
Por que a proteína é reduzida no consumo
de frango com pele e de carne suína com
gordura? A proteína é reduzida? Não, não
é reduzida não. Talvez esteja falando
que a velocidade de digestão da
proteína,
ela é mais lenta quando você come com a
gordura, tá? Porque os o esvazeamento
gástico é mais lento, tá?
Então não sei de onde você pegou essa
informação, mas não não é isso não, tá?
Agora, tendo a visão funcional, a gente
pensa que a gordura da a gordura
saturada da carne não é um grande vilão,
tá? Apesar disso é uma grande briga aí
na literatura.
A gente pensa que as gorduras
processadas artificiais é que são os
grandes vilões, especialmente a gordura
interestificada
e a gordura trans, né, que é também con
gordura hidrogenada,
certo? E a gordura saturada tem muito
menos oxidação do que as gorduras
eh do tipo omega6, porque tem nos óleos
vegetais aí, óleo de soja, milho, canola
e geraçol.
Qual é a dosagem ideal de cálcio para
mulher com 64 anos? É na faixa de 1200
mg de cálcio por dia, tá? Na forma de
cálcio. Eh,
não é carbonato de cálcio. Deixa eu
lembrar aqui o a forma do cálcio. É
cálcio me fugiu agora.
É malato, acho que é isso. Pera aí,
deixa eu olhar aqui. Eu tenho no no
prontuário eletrônico que eu me fui deu
um branco agora aqui. Calço e trato
malato. Lembrei agora. A melhor forma é
calço se trato malato, tá? 1200 mg por
dia.
Sempre associado ao magnésio, tá? Sempre
associado ao magnésio.
Aí, óbvio, né? Não precisa nem falar. Já
falei isso 200.000 vezes. Vitamina D,
K2,
né? Vitamina A.
O cobre, o zinco, o próprio silício,
boro, tudo isso ajuda no osso, tá?
Exposição solar para aumentar a vitamina
D, não lembrar, não esquecer disso.
Cuidado intestino para melhorar a
absorção desses nutrientes todos.
Beleza?
Qual a dosagem ideal de vitamina C 2 g
liposomal para mulher com 64? Vai, você
já colocou a dose aí?
Começa então de uma a duas cápsulas por
dia.
Toma cuidado com a hidratação. Como eu
falei, a vitamina C aumenta muito
oxalato. Ele é metabolizado em oxalato.
Então se você tiver desidratada e tiver
predisposição a formar pedra, pode dar
problema. Então tem que estar muito bem
hidratada.
Então você poderia estar tomando um por
dia ou dois por dia, tá? Começa com um
por dia
nessa dose que você tá colocando a
lipossomal aí que vai aumentar a
absorção.
Agora,
sendo lipossomol, você pode estar
diminuindo a dose depois, tá? Para 500
mg. Não necessariamente tá usando essa
dose não.
Adulto, 64 anos, 60 kg, que come mais ou
menos 100 g de carne, três ovos por dia.
Devo suplementar proteína? Depende. Você
falou a idade e o peso, mas não falou
qual é o nível de atividade física, né?
Tem que ver se essa conta você tá
fazendo, né?
Ã,
vamos lá. Então, se for 100 g de carne,
três ovos por dia, isso vai dar entre 40
e 50 g de área de proteína. O
recomendado vai ser 1 a 1,2 g por kg de
peso corporal, se não for
fisiculturista. Se for fisciculturista,
aumenta até para 2 g por kg peso dia,
né? Ah, com 60 kg
deveria estar consumindo entre 60 a 72 g
de proteína. Agora você tem que também
fazer as contas, porque as pessoas
pensam só tem proteína na carne e no
ovo, não tem. Tem proteína no arroz, tem
proteína em vários vegetais, tá? Então
tem que fazer a conta completa, ver os
outros alimentos, o feijão, o arroz que
tem proteína, os dois.
Ã, tá? Porque não é só fazer conta com
carne e ovo, não,
mas pode tá suplementando coi proteína,
eh, por exemplo, também do da ervilha,
do arroz, do cânamo, é o a proteína
albumina, que é do ovo, né, o colágeno.
OK,
mas tem que fazer a conta completa. Tem
um aplicativo chamado Cronometer.
Você pode estar baixando aí da
da loja, né, da Apple ou da loja do,
como é que fala? Do Android,
que ele é muito bom para fazer esses
cálculos de macros, tá? Uma cronômeter.
Aí coloca todos os alimentos lá, porque
não tem proteína só nas carnes e ovos,
não tem em outros alimentos, tá?
H, qual a sua avaliação sobre o produto
ISOFT Plante da Vitafor? A Vitafor é um
é uma empresa confiável, tá? Eh, nunca
tive problema com essa empresa. Esse
produto é um produto de qualidade, sim.
Tá?
Ele tem 80% de concentração de proteína
vegetal, tem 4 g de BCA por porção,
tem aquele gosto de adoçante que é meio
desagradável, né?
Então é uma essas proteínas aí de planta
geralmente tem um gosto pior do que o E
protein, tá?
Então pode estar enjuando isso daí
e o custo dele pode ser um pouco alto
também, tá?
Por favor, como entrar no site das
aulas? Site das aulas. Que site das
aulas que tá falando?
Eu não entendi. Você tá, você tá ao
vivo, Maria?
Porque assim, eu tô criando uma
plataforma de cursos. Tá, mas inclusive
vai ser uma mensalidade
fixa e a pessoa enquanto tiver pagando
por mês vai ter acesso ao material. Mas
eu não sei se tá querendo dizer com o
site das aulas aí. Preciso entender
melhor o que você tá falando.
Bem, vamos ver aqui as perguntas ao
vivo. O Eliseu adora jogar umas 10, 15
por live. Vamos ver.
Na live passada você disse que a posição
de tremendurg na digestão. Não.
Pergunta. A posição de tremendurg ativa
o parassimpático? Sim, pode ativar o
parassimpático pode ajudar a dormir
melhor.
Eu não conheço muito bem a medicina
germânica, viu, Eliseu? Eu acho que ela
tem aspectos interessantes porque ela
faz uma correlação entre
eh várias doenças com a parte de psiquê,
mas hoje eu tô muito mais inclinado a
usar
a visão da homeopatia ranemaniana,
que também vê muito bem essa parte
emocional, tá? do que a medicina
germânica, mas eu não conheço tão bem
para falar mal ou bem, mas sim é uma
disciplina fascinante.
Consumir eletrólicos é a melhor opção
para pessoa com constipação intestinal
no início da data carnívora.
Você deve consumir eletrólitos, tá? Se a
pessoa tiver fazendo uma dieta também
que vai induzir cetose, que aí a quando
a pessoa começa a perder o glicogênio,
né, que tá armazenado em músculo e
fígado, pode acontecer
da pessoa ter uma desidratação e perda
de minerais, tá? Mas não por causa de
constipação.
Quando você sugere adicionar verdura na
dieta carnívora, é por causa da fibra?
Sim.
E não é qualquer verdura, tá? Você pode
est eh restringindo a a salada, né? A
hortaliças cruas, a tomate, não precisa
comer todos os vegetais, não. Mas eu
acho, aliás, na verdade acho quase
ninguém come dieta carnívora do jeito
que é proposto mesmo, né? As pessoas
falam que estão fazendo carnívora, na
maioridade acaba comendo vegetal. É
muito difícil ter alguém fazendo
carnívora realmente estrita, comendo só
víceera e carne.
Dia da carnívora mimetiza o jejum. Não,
porque a proteína é digerida em
aminoácido e aminoácido tira o jejum.
Para quem vai fazer a transição da dieta
low cararve para a dieta carnívora,
quais suplementos você recomenda
para acompanhar a pessoa? Olha, é mais
se preocupar com as vitaminas que não
tem nas carnes. Vitamina C, por exemplo,
né? É bem importante tá dando uma olhada
nisso.
Ã, magnésio também é outro mineral que
tem que estar muito atento, tá? E vai
depender se você tá fazendo realmente a
a carnívora do jeito que eles propõem,
que quase ninguém faz. Se você tiver
comendo, sei lá, alface, tiver comendo
covid, já não tá fazendo direita
carnívora, né? Mas muita gente chama de
carnívora, só porque come muito mais
carne que o o resto das coisas.
Ahã.
Deixa eu ver se tem mais perguntas aqui.
OK. OK. OK.
Ainda resisto tomar metatorexato e
imunobiológico para psorias e convivo
com a psorias há 8 anos usando apenas a
pomada da Ivobet. não melhoram e venho
observando uma extensão maior das
lesões. Olha que eu tenho para te dizer,
Luciano, dá uma investigada no seu
intestino, tá? Tem muita gente que
melhora muito da psoríase
com a questão intestinal. Se você fazer
um tratamento aí de liquigat, outra dica
que eu te dou usandoxon de baixa
dosagem, então LDN e vitamina D em altas
doses, protocolo Coimbra, tá? Pensa
nessas coisas aí.
Eu
acabei de responder essa pergunta.
Nunca vi resultado bom com oxitocina.
Tem alguém que concorda comigo?
Eu acho os resultados que eu tive na
prática foram decepcionantes, tá? Eu
gostaria de falar
uma outra coisa.
Gosta muito deitocina? Beleza, pode
gostar, não tem problema nenhum. Eu
também não tenho nada contra não. Só tô
falando que na prática eu não vi grandes
resultados, tá?
Ah, a questão dos parasitas mais
relacionadas às toxinas que liberam,
funcionando de maneira indireta,
deixando meio tóxico, que favorece ao
câncer. Sim, é um dos fatores, tá? Só
que tem vários outros fatores e o
pessoal dá muita ênfase a parasita e eu
acho que não é por aí, tá? Minha
opinião. Não tem problema nenhum ter
opinião diferente da minha, não.
Amador treinando por uma maratona. Então
não mexe com isso não, ô Angelo. Não
mexe com Cardarine, não. Não vale a pena
não.
Já tive 120 kg, hoje tem 80. Esse
domingo corri 21 km. Sabe qual que é o
problema? Vocês ficam muito
animados para correr distâncias longas,
né? O pessoal não consegue se
contentar com 10 km. Tem que correr uma
porrada de quilômetro.
Depois de 10 km, você vai ter mais
malefício da corrida do que benefício,
tá? Vai no que eu tô te falando, vai na
minha opinião que você vai se dar bem,
tá? Não inventa de correr mais de 10 km.
Eu sei que dá muita vontade, relaxa. Meu
irmão também adora correr para caramba
porque relaxa, porque desestressa,
porque tem desempenho, porque ganha
medalha, porque não sei o quê. Mas
começa a ferrar joelho que nem tem o
joelho ferrado, começa a ferrar eh como
é que fala? Quadril, começa a ferrar eh
tornozelo. Não vale a pena, tá? Não vale
a pena. Eu sei que vocês não vão
escutar, vocês vão continuar correndo
que nem cavalo, mas não vale a pena.
Uai, onde está lendo essas perguntas?
Você não viu eu mostrando as perguntas
na tela?
Não entendi isso não.
A pipoca feita com pouco azeite, pouco
sal, você considera de alto índice
glicêmico? Ela é de alto índice
glicêmico, só que o azeite
vai ajudar, tá, a diminuir um pouco o
índice glicêmico.
Fui eu, Marisa, que não vi também. Vi o
quê?
Não entendi. É porque a pessoa vai
escutando o que eu tô falando e ela vai
jogando na mesma hora que eu falei, só
que ela não coloca, coloca o contexto.
Depois eu vou ver, não consigo entender.
Como diz Passile o equilíbrio. Com
certeza. Com certeza.
Passileu é excelente médico.
Toninho Passileu.
Ah, consegui expandir.
Último link.
Bem, pessoal, é isso aí. Já estamos com
1 hora20 de live. Vou encerrar aqui, tá?
Vou encerrar aqui, tá?
O resultado da oxitocina,
tá? Não sei, não tô entendendo muito bem
essa sequência aqui não. Bem, pessoal,
muito obrigado pela presença de vocês.
Eu tava olhando o documento hoje, tá, da
resumo das lives, ele tá meio
desatualizado, tá? E eu vou explicar a
vocês para vocês por está. Eu tô tendo
problemas com a API do YouTube, tá? O
YouTube é muito chato com a API e eles
não deixam baixar muita transcrição com
muita frequência, tá? Eu tô tentando
resolver isso. Eu mandei uma comunicação
lá para eles aumentarem meu limite de
API. Então, eu peço desculpas que o
documento tá parado no dia 25 de
novembro, mas assim que eles aumentarem
o meu acesso de API lá, eu consigo
atualizar isso aqui, tá bom?
Eh, Dr. Orlando,
você colocou no documento a tua
pergunta. Isso aqui, gente, isso aqui
atualiza em tempo real, tá? Então, se
vocês não colocou a pergunta no
documento, ó, vamos ver se tem um
Orlando aqui,
ó. São 30 perguntas no documento. Se
você não colocou, gente, ah, não é para
colocar ao vivo a pergunta, tá? porque é
mais difícil de acompanhar. Eu tô, eu
até respondi umas perguntas ao vivo
aqui, porque
eh, mas às vezes vocês colocam, eu perco
a pergunta ao vivo, tá? É para colocar
no documento. E não tem nenhum Orlando
aqui, ó. Tá vendo, ó? Tô voltando aqui,
ó.
Ã, Eduardo Mateus,
ó, não tem o LAN documento aqui, tá?
Não tem. Então, não sei se você colocou
ao vivo, né?
Tá, Luí, vamos fazer o seguinte. Eh,
faça a pergunta agora, tá? Eu vou
esperar um minuto para você fazer a
pergunta e te respondo que não tá no
documento.
Ah, você tá me chamando de Dr. Orlando.
É Dr. Alan. Tá, Luiz. Ah, tava lendo
Orlando. Olha que viajando. É Luís
Henrique Ribeiro. Vamos lá. Mais o Luís
Henrique Ribeiro,
eu ver se tem aqui no documento.
É esse aqui. É, Luís, essa pergunta do
da insulina eu respondi. Tal vez você
foi no banheiro na hora que eu respondi.
Não sei se é essa que tu tá falando.
Esperar você colocar ao vivo aí. Vou ver
se a mesma pergunta.
Não, vamos ver.
Não, você falou que é sobre HPB.
Às vezes eles não salvaram. Quem não
salvou documento? Ele salva sim, viu?
Você tá me escutando, Luiz? Ou não? Eu
vou dar mais um minuto para você. Se
você não perguntar ao vivo aqui, eu você
deixa a pergunta pra próxima live, tá?
Pra semana que vem.
Era bom que tivesse um mecanismo de
busca aqui nessas nesses comentários,
né? Era muito mais fácil, né?
Mas não tem.
que eu sabe, pelo menos eu não acho que
é, não tem mesmo. Ah, tá aqui a
pergunta. Homens com HPB sentem dores na
região pélvica? Sim, é possível, mas
geralmente quem tem dor na região
pélvica por próstata tem prostatite
associado. Então, geralmente são pessoas
que têm HPB, que é peplasia, mais a
prostatite crônica associada, tá?
Não é um sintoma muito comum dor pélvica
para quem tem HPB puro sem prostatite,
mas é possível, mas é muito mais comum a
associação do HPB com prostatite, tá
bom?
Então, se é normal, normal é não ter
dor, né? Então não é normal, mas é comum
sim pessoas com HPB desenvolverem
prostatite.
correm porque existe uma inflamação
crônica no tecido e essa inflamação gera
estímulo ao receptores de dor da
próstata, da musculatura em volta e as
raízes nervosas ali da coluna são
estimuladas e provoca sintomas que pode
ser dor na coxa, dor suprapúbica, dor
abdominal, pode ser dor lombar baixa,
tá? Por conta da inflamação que às vezes
é por infecção e muitas vezes não é. é
uma inflamação asséptica
ou às vezes pode ser até por vírus.
Tá bom? Beleza. Então já respondi essa
pergunta, pessoal. Muito obrigado aí
pela presença de vocês. Lembrando que
todas as lives ficam gravadas para quem
é novo. Vocês podem revisar, tá bom? E
nos vemos semana que vem. Ah, esse
domingo eu vou fazer a live do grupo
dois, tá?
do grupo avançado, que eu acabei não
fazendo antes porque tava muito próximo
do ano novo e eu fiz uma pesquisa, uma
enquete lá no YouTube e pouquíssima
gente respondeu, tá? Então eu vou fazer
nesse domingo uma nova live aí da do
grupo nível dois.
Sim, tem tratamento a prostatite, tá?
Tem vários eh elementos naturais aí, sal
palmeto, pigo africano, tiga de oica,
extrato aí de betaacitosterol, que é
extraído do bacateiro,
tem licopeno, tem bromelina, tem
quecetina, tem muita coisa dá para
tratar, tá bom? Abraço para vocês, até a
próxima. Ciao. Ciao.